war
[music]
let's go but
and there lay down
[music]
what a
feeling because of course it's a pity
right now for all those civilians who
in Ukraine all the little children thorn all the
old people
who suffer for no reason now of
course very very sorry for them
rather, I just add a sense of
patriotism, pride in our country and the
understanding that not a single enemy will break us,
so the desire to even show everyone even more
that we are such a country that
we will not bow our heads to anyone
[music]
my son is
finishing a master's program, I am very
I was very afraid, I know from mothers
whose walls have children of military
age, they now can’t find a
place for themselves, they didn’t know the pressure, they
can’t, they don’t know what to do, and so
on, that is, they would
hide their children by any means so that the children would not go
to  war
we will hold the dawn operation
[music]
but in general I remember our grandfathers
who fought
let's say we probably had no choice
we were forced into  go in anthracite color to
protect not all killing units how it burns
in general people who are against Nazism